[Music]
welcome back to the general Julian
podcast this week we are broadcasting
live from outer space we made it it was
quite the trip for we did it
now we freeze-dried strawberries beat
that would be so horrible that would be
the my least favorite thing about being
in outer space the food mine would just
be like not being able to sleep I would
be fine sleeping but I would be eating
food that I would prefer not to be
eating ever sleeping in 0g what about
like pooping and peeing in zero-g um I
haven't heard of anyone getting good pad
thai in zero-g and that's a big problem
for me honestly so we're gonna have to
sort that out before you're gonna take
me to space well we're already here well
I brought my own pad thai it's just
flying everywhere
guys this this week's episodes brought
to you by texture guys who doesn't love
a good magazine you know mm-hmm what I
don't love about the magazine system is
paying the overpriced fees and prices
for them especially when you're at
places like the airport where I marked
all the way up texture is there to solve
that problem okay texture lets you read
all your favorite magazines on your on
your devices on your phone your tablets
or your computers you can download your
favorite magazines you can you have
access to so many magazines guys and it
just starts for $9.99 a month it's $9.99
a month over 30% off the listed price of
texture when you use texture comm slash
Jenna Julian that's texture txt ure comm
slash annejulien or click the link in
our description get started you say the
earth no one's no one's having to print
all those useless papers that you're
really just gonna throw out when you're
done with right let's be honest here
texture is onto something also guys this
skin guys to get you information in a
concise functional form the the skin is
there for you okay it's a daily
newsletter comes to your inbox and it's
free by the way all you got to do is
subscribe and you get the email and
that's it that's all we're asking you to
do it serves up the news that I
personally think is the most important
it's concise it has all the points you
need without all the
mumbo-jumbo that's out there and right
now guys if you go to this skim that's
th e sk IM m comm slash annejulien you
were entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card
when you subscribe check it out it's a
great way to get your information the
end thank you sponsored gracias
thanks for sponsoring us do you won
there Phil it is pretty cool that people
pay us money because they like the way
we talk or something is that why to
support us yeah it might not like where
we talk I mean this is like it's kind of
a lot of gear and belongings in here to
start your own podcast yeah yeah I mean
we started with nothing and you could
really tell it's a really tell half the
episodes one of us wasn't InFocus
yeah half the episodes one of us or Mike
wasn't on or it was like twelve minutes
of recording and then you'd have to
block him together
yeah who was I was talking as Dylan
recently because he at Guitar Center and
I was talking about how literally I
didn't realize until maybe like 20
episodes in that the it's not the
refresh rate it's the audio sample rate
of video traditionally as 48 Hertz but a
lot of audio devices don't abide by that
because that's the video standard so a
lot of like recordings or recording
software or USB mics or whatever would
record a 42 I think and so for up until
like I think 20 episodes maybe even
longer I would have to edit the audio
and then about like certain 20 to 30
minutes in I would have to like reset
the next clip because it was acting out
of sync yeah and that's something that
like I literally had to just learn the
hard way over and over in Tom's like you
know what I'm gonna look into this why
is the audio
yeah but yeah it's so frustrating yeah
we've come a long way I suppose like
really though they're still there still
are improvements to be made you can't
see the rest of this room but we've now
sound paneled half of this wall and I
need to do kind of most of that wall
because it still is kind of echo Ian Ian
well I mean be nice eventually to have
like maybe a different setup with
multiple cameras if you ever wanted to
have a guest and we can like sit across
from each other because still like even
though we have this room that's
dedicated we have a very large circle
table that's like when we have guests do
you remember like the first few times we
had guests and we were like okay well
sit them like in the middle and then the
poor persons like looking to me and like
looking to you it's like we've cornered
them we're just talking at them in their
ear but yeah hopefully someday we'll
have like a setup where we can have
guests no we were watching Ryan's new
podcast Ryan he is in the progress I
love right he goes you guys should check
it out it's was it called podcast
ination but I've been waiting forever to
have him and his boys doing house but
everyone always wants us to do stuff
with them they just they live in Vegas
and we live here so it's get on theirs
eventually they also work like you know
they're in the same boat that we are
you're on a never-ending hamster wheel
of like working on your own stuff that
it's like you barely have any time to do
anything and by the way I mean talk
about that video that they just heard
about yeah I mean talking anything
without moving are you [ __ ] kidding
me like we mean we're we love Ryan and
like them in their videos because we're
friends
when nimble and Stan we love them yeah
but like objectively I can't even say
how cool it is that like people who have
been on YouTube for so long that are
continuing to like up their own game
right not because there are other videos
doing the same thing or maybe silent or
it's the meta it's like this is what
Ryan and crew wants to do and so they
came up with that idea of the answer is
I'm moving and like knocked it out of
the [ __ ] Park yeah to the point where
it was like so original I saw it do well
on Reddit as it should have but it's
just it's very cool to see a channel
that's been around so long just continue
to like innovate and be like original
because that's like so few and far
between and you know I mean well like
with any Ryan video genuinely made me
laugh although he genuinely makes me
laugh out loud
yeah hold them do honestly Greg Greg is
probably the funniest person I've ever
met in person he got damn funny
speaking of Greg we need a Greg because
Greg is the one who who edits there well
everything but also over there podcast
so you were talking about having two
angles I I would have loved like a
million years ago to be able to like cut
from who's talking so they had the full
screen cuz that's how a podcast and talk
to us they are and for this it's like
this static weird shot which we're fine
with but if we have a guess though it'd
be nice to at least be able to sit
across from each other yeah so we I
think eventually yeah we're not this is
not the final form of the podcast like
we'd love to have like two cameras and
maybe someone who can cut together
angles and stuff which is not that crazy
yeah but we also don't have guests all
the time so it's not that big of a deal
no we don't but I think it would be cool
to maybe have it for us like whoa you
know two angles one on you one on me I
don't know show the show can I say
something that's been like bothering me
and I've wanted to say on the podcast
for absolutely wild I'm sorry permission
come on and I just want to say something
really positive and happy that I see
occasionally on the internet that makes
me so [ __ ] happy so we used to do a
lot of MMA podcasts a lot of UFC
podcasts and we've since sort of like
fallen off like there's literally a
fight last night that we didn't watch
like there's so many fights on that we
don't watch partly because I think the
UFC is sort of like it's getting a
little old are we open in that box
because I mean maybe not right this
thank you but we used to talk a lot
about Ronda Rousey and what was gonna
happen with her career and that kind of
thing and I just want to say it has been
so wonderful to see such a talented
professional athlete sort of have this
like you know fall from grace in her
career and traditionally that's how it
works with these high stakes sports is
like your career is only so long and
then what are they gonna do and we're
like we're hoping she's not like gonna
depend on this like I'm gonna be an
actress I'm gonna you know do Ronda
Rousey's stuff on you're like how long
can that possibly last if your fight
career is over yeah and she has been
looking so happy and so like wonderful
in the WWE it's been so nice to watch
her have a really happy flourishing
like I'm so happy for her you know she
just got inducted the UFC Hall of Fame
right good for her she deserves it she
absolutely deserve I would agree and I
think I made that observation when I was
like because I follow her on Instagram
and I have forever yeah you know just
seeing her like literally do what she
wants and make a new career out of it I
mean the thing is when like you said
with the high stakes sports that's such
a great way to put it because MMA is
like the highest stakes sport that there
is it's even higher stakes in boxing
because the life span of a career is
just way shorter especially for a female
yeah and like she rose to the top so
fast
but I still don't even think she was
given the credit that she was due
because she was so unbelievably dominant
like no one has ever been as dominant as
her arguably John Jones but for I mean
Ronda was it was like a different
species fighting other fighting humans
and what she did for the sport for women
will never ever be you know forgotten
because of how well the UFC has done
after Rhonda with women fighters and I
think it is incredibly cool to see
someone like that who deserves to find
happiness and longevity in a career like
that and to Bank a new career off of
what she had done she deserves whatever
she wants out I agree and it sucks like
the thought of someone being such a
pioneer for the sport and being such a
legend then having to like you know go
back to like traditional work because
something didn't work in because the
lifestyle that's so sad like I'm glad
that she gets gets the time of day in
WWE and I'm glad she's happy doing it
and the you know her fans are so happy
for I know like the last few times that
I've seen Ronda Rousey like trending on
Twitter it's because the I don't watch
WWE but I know it's massive and I know
the fans are like diehard and it's so
entertaining and fun and amazing people
love it but like it's so wonderful to
log onto Twitter and see her name
trending and see people talking about
how they love her in the WWE and that
they're so excited about it it's really
rad but I'm like I could only hope that
there was that that Forbes 100 list for
athletes that just came out this year
that was like the top 100 highest-paid
athletes and for the first time ever I
think no not ever
but like in the last
in a recent amount of years there was
not a single woman on there not a single
one and it was Serena Williams or Venus
Williams it was on Serena that was on
there last year and like you know some
low spot and because she took a year off
to have her baby was there's now no
female highest-paid athlete in 100
athletes it's so [ __ ] so like and I
knew this I knew this sad reality when
they chose to play softball first of all
when I started in gymnastics I know that
my peak age is like 15 16 then it's like
you could go to college and play or you
know do gymnastics but like likely
you're not gonna you know do anything
after that like you go into that
gymnastics world with this wildly
competitive attitude it's like you're
either gonna do something by the time
you're 14 15 16 or it's like you're
doing this as a hobby yeah you know I
mean and I did I joined a competitive
team and I was like I hate it I want to
die every day so then I was like I'm
gonna take softball pretty seriously and
I played all the way through college I
played NCAA softball for four years yeah
we should finish her college career is
already a relatively low statistic but
we know after that if you want to pursue
like that athletics like you could be a
coach but like you could you know run
clinics or you could work in sports
psychology which is what I chose but
it's like there is no job for you really
as a professional female softball player
like if you find them they're very low
paying if at all like they took it out
of the Olympics like there is no future
for you so you talk about tennis you
talk about MMA you talk about some of
these other sports where females can
potentially make a or WNBA you can make
a living playing pro like you will never
get hopefully not never in the future
but like at this point right now you
know that you're never gonna be paid
like LeBron James or you know Kobe
Bryant like there's just not that
opportunity for you even if you are the
best in the world you are Serena
Williams you are Ronda Rousey there's
still that much of a discrepancy in pay
but to be able to to watch Rhonda's
career in theory for what she trained
for be over and continue to be able to
earn a living in a way that makes her
happy that allows her to be physical
still you know very athletic it's just
like it makes me so happy and it makes
me really hopeful for the future for
other female athletes that and I imagine
I'm forgetting people that you guys will
remind me of in the comments but it's
just really nice to watch someone like
continue to have a career you know
because it's been done by men like Brock
Lesnar has done it in the WWE yeah and
like not that that needs to be the go-to
for MMA fighters so like oh we'll just
go in the shop you be like I hope so
but it's really nice to watch someone
have a career in you know pseudo
entertainment after their fight career
ends I agree I agree and I think man or
woman the MMA community is oftentimes
brutal it's brutal
they chew fighters up and they spit them
out and without really realizing that
not only have they trained so many years
to become an MMA fighter at a
professional level they sacrifice their
whole life not only that but prior to
that they probably were upper a
perfectionist or a professional at some
other martial art like Ronda wasn't judo
and like so many these guys are in
wrestling boxing or jiu-jitsu yeah
they've spent years years decades of
their lives perfecting a martial art
just to parlay it into a mixed martial
arts because it was lucrative and then
they have a three four year career and
people are like yeah they're washed up
that's brutal
yeah that's brutal especially when
you're out there competing with your
with your body and law and with your
health on the line with your
consciousness each night on the way you
can lose consciousness and wake up
that's in front of brain down hundreds
of thousands of people a bloody mess not
knowing where you are maybe just pissed
your pants it's [ __ ] - it's sad it's
really sad as much as I'm a huge fan of
MMA and as I was a huge fan years ago
before the UFC kind of made some weird
decisions it is a brutal sport through
and through so it is especially nice to
see a mixed martial artist who did so
much the sport and had really put her
whole life to becoming a judoka
professional and bronze olympian
medalists like succeed because if anyone
deserves to like make it in the WWE sure
it's like popular like really popular
celebrities who know how to
on a show the rock or what I mean the
rock is about exam because he's put on
you know years and years and years of
athletic athletics under his belt like
he's he played college and pro football
and I never but like if anyone deserves
that's why I think it's someone like
runner so I basically just echo what you
said it's cool it's cool I think it's
just like it's so nice to see her on
Instagram and she's like happy mm-hmm
like cuz she doesn't that although I'm
sure the WWE brings a whole new slew of
pressure and stress and all of that onto
her like it's not the same type of
straddling will ever make yeah we used
to rag on her and I think a lot of
people datalog a lot of people did not
like her because she had this attitude
you know about winning and about you
know just everything in general it was
really you know people saw his bad
sportsmanship is all that stuff but now
that she is in an entertainment field in
theory it she seems [ __ ] happy isn't
that like when you're a fan of someone
that's what it makes you so happy to see
someone that you like happy yeah it's
really nice
yeah yep I I'm a big fan of Carlos
Condit and he is recently retired I
think for the second time and it breaks
my heart to see him lose because I know
that like he's he's passed the point of
like being a champion competitor and
that's just the way it is like you have
a lifespan but I've always just like
loved his fighting and have loved his
work ethic and his personality and I've
just been like a through-and-through fan
of his and it you know I remember like
six or eight months ago he was on the
MMA hour you did an interview with Ariel
Helwani and he was he was asked like why
why did you come back we didn't expect
it like what was the decision he's like
dude I got one skill and I need to feed
my family and that breaks my heart
it just is so sad to hear especially
when he already has been so successful
in the sport you're like what where is
the money like what the hell and that's
one of the major reasons why I just like
I can't support the UFC like I used to I
just can't so they make these fighters
like slaves to their company and they
don't pay him well and whatever but kind
of on a more positive note he started
his coffee company and I was like [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna fall in this coffee
company and like I'm gonna support the
[ __ ] out of I'll buy their cochlear cold
brew and then they
follow me back of excrement I was like
yeah it's like you just want your idols
of the people you look up to or fans of
to in just the most simple sense you
just want them to find happiness yeah
and it makes sense because like a lot of
you guys are so wonderful and like you
tweet things at us like oh it's so great
to see you happy yeah and sometimes it's
like well why like what do you care you
know but it in the kindest way in the
kindest way it's like I'm really
surprised that people care yeah yeah
it's like I appreciate of course and
it's so wonderful to get that but like
why why yeah and I get that from being a
fan of other things and people but yeah
that's funny that you brought that up
because I was thinking about that the
other day I just don't she's like on a
ranch I'm like well cuz I'm like low-key
back on Instagram like a little bit I
mean I'm not below kyani I'm not like
you're posting pictures that were neat
that I'm like occasionally dabbling in
stories and visiting and looking at
other people's stuff I'm lurking you're
back on Instagram there's no monkey and
I mean mmm
she back but I was I was watching her
story and oh yeah I was watching her
take care of ducklings and like spend
time like at home and I'm like this is
so [ __ ] nice because every you know
piece that you've ever seen about Ronda
Rousey's she's just like riddled with
stress and [ __ ] pressure and you just
can't even imagine what that's like just
seems really nice
it is cool I kind of wanted to talk
about some some of the stuff that was
dropped at e3 we're traditionally not
like a gaming podcast you see [ __ ] hey
we're here for our [ __ ] interest in
that I changed week to week but if you
didn't catch up on III it's still
happening it's all through the weekend
I'm going on Tuesday I'm sorry y'all
won't be there that's okay I will miss
you sorry just like going I know you
gonna have fun without me though yeah
I'm going with Jason we're gonna go I'm
actually really excited
I've never been to e3 I've always wanted
to go it's in LA I could have gone so
many times but I've never really had a
reason to go I've never been this
ingrained in the gaming pink community
mm-hm so I'm excited because I feel like
it's finally the right time to go hmm
I'm excited to meet some people
you know and just kind of like go go
have a thing I don't have any obligation
so which was nice I don't have to be on
like a pan or anything which is yeah I'm
just going to go yeah it's kind of cool
and there's been some cool updates
released so far oh my god which if you
guys haven't been following along with
e3 I'm sure maybe some of the bigger
updates that trailer for cyberpunk looks
incredible oh my god what's happening oh
my god what are you doing oh it's this
video that's playing the court oh my god
yes yeah like I don't I was saying like
if you haven't seen it look up trailer
for cyberpunk it's it's incredibly cool
looking game but like I don't even know
what the game is yet but the world that
they created yes bad I imagine the story
is badass yeah which is what I'm looking
for yeah and you were like oh there's a
new trailer for the new life is strange
and I'll get Julian a little bit because
first of all you did not play the whole
first one through I played the whole
first one through I was there we did not
finish the second one because it was it
was pretty cringe it was hard
I switched voice actors you can't do
that from a part one to a part two yeah
I mean like I we streamed the first
little bit of it and everyone was like
just give it a chance like you guys are
making fun of it too much and I'm like
I'm sorry I'm not trying to prep on it
too much but it is a little frustrating
I'd say to play that live streaming oh
yeah I might finish a second one like on
my own yeah that time but if the third
one is a little better I'd be down and
play it plus it's fun like this stream
likes when we play Story games on
occasion because we we just play pop G
at this point I know and like we could
we could definitely be do doing a better
job of being quote-unquote variety
streamers yeah we're doing a bad job I'm
very sorry but there's a spin-off I
think it's like a spin-off game that was
announced by Square Enix it's the
adventures of captain spirit which i
think is in the same world as life is
strange did either of the one of their
names
strange the girls Chloe and Max did
either of them have a brother younger
brother I don't know where the captain
regardless it looks like a spin-off game
that I haven't really I saw a trailer
for it but that's fun it looks cool
letter I'm
okay so let me tell you I am so excited
for Halo infinity holy [ __ ] I saw that
trailer Chris showed us that trailer
because I didn't know was announced yet
but nobody knows what it is yet
well it's I feel like it's likely about
around that's the logical well because
they said it's for PC right yes oh
that's like the most except even even if
it wasn't about alright I'm excited for
the fact that it's on PC because so many
games that you just want to [ __ ] play
on PC come out on console now mmm-hmm
are you looking up that no I wouldn't do
that you wouldn't do that
mmm-hmm I feel like you would what I
feel like you would do that that's
something that you would do is look up
what would I do
you would complain what I I wouldn't I
didn't do anything
[Music]
I was I was trying to play this while
you're talking about halo sleeping
getting okay yeah so they basically
released a really small teaser where
they showed just nostalgia in halo form
with the warthogs driving around and
Master Chief with his helmet and just
just in rhinos not rhinoceri how do you
say right now sources Joe and that's
right I know sir I running around
happily but you know what you don't have
to take our word for it because if this
announcement is big enough at e3 and
enough [ __ ] gets talked about you know
where it's gonna end up boy don't do it
newsletter right now guys if you want
all the up-to-date big news out in the
world whether it's at e3 or it's in the
government or it's in the box offices
you want to know about it and you don't
want the the fluff that's guarding all
the important information online the
skim does that for you guys it's
delivered to your inbox each morning and
has all the news and info you need to
start your day and it's completely free
okay that's all it is you don't have to
read everything they just give you the
nice cliff notes okay if you ever we're
in school and you didn't read the book
that you were supposed to you read the
cliff notes okay this game is that for
hey I skim is that for life okay yeah
yeah sure well our goal okay well for
those of you you know who you are who
maybe just you know got a little
distracted didn't have time to read the
whole chapter you pop down little spark
notes cliff notes that's what the skin
is except it's not you cannot judge
denied use the skin I'm not naughty
naughty guys the skin serves up the news
it's you can devour it nice and fast is
like a little snack with 2 C's it's
wonderful you'll be a good company
because 4 million people currently wake
up to the skin every morning including
Oprah Sarah Jessica Parker my personal
favorite and Stephen Colbert what I
showed you a yeah probably
she had Hathaway cuz if she's not then I
could pick her out of a lineup also guys
you could be entered to win a $250 Visa
gift card when you go to the skim that's
th
eske IMM calm sausage annejulien
register and subscribe to the newsletter
you won't regret it
also guys when you want to read your
magazines don't grab those thick pieces
of paper charged ten bucks 20 bucks
however much in an airport little market
get your texture and get your stuff
sorted so that when you're ready to read
your new men's health Men's Fitness
Women's Health National Geographic I
don't know what anything any other oprah
weekly that's not amazing you have oh
maggie zine you haven't already on your
texture whether it's through the texture
app on your phone your tablet or your
computer you can have them already
paperless you're saving the earth it's a
better way to read your favorite
magazines they deliver the app delivers
unlimited access to over 200 premium and
magazines and right now you can try it
for free at texture comm slash
annejulien
okay starts with just $9.99 a month but
you can give it a spin
give a spin alright see how you like it
hop in the driver seat
give it a little Rev okay don't be
holding paper that you're just gonna
trash just I mean like I remember it's
like an old thing when you go into a
bathroom there's like a stack of
magazines I mean come on that's that's
grandpa's stuff now you have your device
get your get your magazines on your
device none of us go to the bathroom
without this thing anyway alright go to
texture comm slash Jenna Julianne to
start your free trial to day thank you
sponsored thanks sponsors so they let's
see I wanted to talk about the Red Dead
Redemption had a trailer I didn't play
the first one I did yeah one before we
had a twitch channel a long time ago I
played the first one in college with a
roommate of mine we kind of play it
together like I would laser me do I know
him you don't he was he was my freshman
roommate you never met them shots out to
had him with me and also black ops with
me and also watching all of renown I'm a
month me Wow
sounds like a pal real pal wow he's not
the one that would sit on the weights
and scoot across the room in the gym no
that was us my buddy he was not a
roommate of mine
just a friend he was just a friend we
would be workout partners he was a
soccer player and so we would go to the
athletic play room together and he was
small like he was just short small guy
he was a soccer player I didn't need to
be big but he was quick and he was
athletic and we used to go do the cable
row machine where you grabbed the cables
down you either do like standing rows
but you do like then they're like you
know kind of seated rows or whatever so
he would take the cables and he would
back himself all the way up across the
whole life letting Jim just let go of
his feet and slide across the floor so
dangerous and I just remember that was
my experience having a workout partner
in college but not that was an agreement
that was good times though what there
was one other thing
oh yeah Bethesda they're gonna announce
something I think like should I check to
see if it's been announced I think they
don'ts the fallout thing but I hope
Skyrim for iPhone beads their big
announcement 9:30 oh okay well with the
mean B okay so it's it's in 30 minutes
it's we're literally like recording
these pockets right before the date
because that that's me is this skyrim
for your Apple watch hey guys please buy
Skyrim again now on Apple watch okay
Beach okay would you play it if it was
Lenny or what no I would never play it
if it was such a complex game how would
you play with two buttons can they get
you know fortnight came out for a switch
right that it yeah oh they're really on
everything men what do you thought what
are your thoughts on um the pub G winter
math and everything works I'm excited
the riot shield you're kicking the court
sir I like it like a noise it's making
noise I like it oh you were an audio
producer and you would like a job please
every time I've ever gone somewhere
where someone else has to make me up
like I'm everything I've ever done
outside I know what you're gonna say
they always I wear all my jewelry and
stuff I've been wearing the same like
chains and necklaces really here's and I
always put them on and the audio person
always tells me to take them off
so that's noisy as hell [ __ ] but all
what also happens you know better and
I'm like always hoping maybe this time
will be different what also happens in
that scenario is they're reaching around
your body to Mike you up and you make
the joke that they're going to second
base on you and then they get really
uncomfortable oh yes and then they're
like blush blush sweating it's funny it
breaks yeah it does but it is a funny
joke because I've seen you make that
joke on so many people who are just
unassuming cuz they're being all nice
and like shy cuz I have to always like
reach down my shirt it's sort of and I'm
like oh I didn't know we're gonna go
with thick of me today what made you
want to get into other engineering going
to still making you know they're always
so respectful and like don't even make
eye contact and they're like can you can
you put this down your shirt from you
know I'll try and grab it out in the
back here and like you gonna clip it
come out underwear maybe you just my
pants what speaking of underwear how are
you enjoying being on a homeowner with a
pool I feel like it's been quite the
change in our lifestyle at least four
weekends yeah big time for weekends
absolutely to wake up on Saturday we're
like let's go outside
yeah I feel like as many you guys know I
was like severely vitamin D deficient to
the point where I was taking one pill a
month that was fifty thousand thousand
IU yeah
and I know people other people have
tweeted at me too that they've recently
got diagnosed with that same thing yeah
like being able to go outside in a place
that like makes you happy is the biggest
luxury I think ever you know having a
happy outdoor space because even we went
back to our old house like that was a
more than decent backyard that we had in
our old house and um the way that it was
just configured and the tiles on the
ground like it felt like 30 degrees
hotter out there than it did here yeah
there's like no air that through that
back it was so hot and it's weird and
just like oh it felt so bizarre yeah but
like you know to be outside and in a
place that like has a breeze and like
you're getting you feel like you're
getting sunshine and fresh air it has
really been life-changing yeah because I
feel like I'm getting
light and it's making me a better person
I mean when you work on the internet you
get trapped in this cycle that's a joke
that everyone makes every you do work
you know we don't go outside like it's
nice we literally don't go outside
yeah and up until the point where we've
now had a nice backyard that we like in
pool and whatever like some house
outside space of our own it's been so
amazing what it does for your mood even
just a couple hours a day a couple
minutes a day whatever you're just
there's a lot of people that say the
vitamin D really acts more like a
hormone then then vitamin you know
really it's it like does a lot for your
mood but like I'm also a person that
came from the east and like we would
have 300 days of overcast a year you
know the same amount of sunshine that
there is in Los Angeles we would have
overcast and you really sort of your
body sort of depends on those summer
months to go outside and like make some
vitamin D and you're just like the
second it's nice out like everybody's
outside like everybody's doing you know
I feel like in Boston and Rochester like
the place is where I lived previously
everyone is seizing those summer Mike
months so hard like we need to have a
plan we're going to the beach at 7 a.m.
like you know what I mean whereas here
it like I always thought that if I moved
here I would be this like outdoor person
and like you can do so much outside but
because it's like it all the time and
because you can do so much outside you
sort of start to take it for granted
yeah really do well that I mean that
happens like you live in a place a long
time just yeah well that and in
combination with working on the Internet
yeah just like the weird combo it's
weird it's so weird to live in such a
beautiful place and you're just like
well I can't see my laptop's green
outside so I better go inside and the
dogs are happy too
yeah they're very happy and we got to
spend some time with a fourth pup
oh it's jolene jolene I like I love
watching other people's dogs people
always like underestimate how serious I
am I'm like I will always watch your dog
is a pleasure for me to watch your dog
it's more of a favor to you than it is
the person who needs you to watch their
dog I need to watch your dog for me give
them to me
really are well I think that if you're
if you were like a person that had one
dog and then someone's like yeah watch
my two dogs like that's a big change you
know to go from one dog to three dogs
which we already have but like if you're
like us and you're already at the point
where you have like a pack of dogs yeah
just keep throwing them in here means
more for them really honestly makes no
difference to me like when we used to
watch my mom's dog kill you like she's
wild but like it's it's it's no big deal
since you're so much of your day it's
already dedicated to focusing on your
pack of dogs like it's really not a
problem yeah you know I know well
because we talked about getting another
dog and like namely a retired racing
greyhound adoption
yeah opted one and I've been watching
hours of Graham videos yeah it's really
bad ooh also we can switch back to this
in a second but I've also been watching
hours of POV waterslides yeah tell me
about how you got stucked in that I
don't know I just started watching them
it was really cool so they're just if
you type in like POV waterslide cuz I
was like it is a you to be whole for
sure right but it's insane that some of
them have like 87 million views I feel
like every hole that you ever fall down
on YouTube you find those channels that
are just killing it you know wait a
minute channels do this well imagine
being that guy and you upload you know
you had a GoPro on your head as you went
down the waterslide then you're like wow
five million people watch this I better
go back let's make a whole channel yeah
and I mean there's roller coaster ones
there's waterslide I like the waterslide
ones because yeah what about the one
where they're in the chamber and then
the floor just falls out beneath them
and they go straight there that makes me
so nervous Engel drop in is super but
you don't start standing up no you know
those people like get and I'd never seen
them cuz I haven't been to a waterpark
since I was like I don't I took the kids
that I babysat I took them one time to a
waterpark and I'm pretty sure that was
the last time I've ever been to a
waterpark even before that I've only
been to like one before but you like
stand in this chamber and they close the
door and then the floor drops out and
you just drop go straight down and it
goes so fast
like come out yeah you go so fast that
after the drop you go up and back down
to slow you down I mean no thank you no
thank you I mean there's not a lot as an
adult that appeals to me about going to
a water park
forgive me there should be a water park
for adults where there's liquor
everywhere that sounds like a terrible
and there's once you walk in you've you
sign a paper that says whatever happens
happens oh absolutely not
no that happens happens come on baby you
know then you walk in no okay you're
greeted by waitress or waiters holding
pictures of beer
no and then they feed you the pictures
of beer and you walk up the steps to the
tallest slide and you get to the very
top so I'm getting like hives thinking
about drunk people climbing up tall and
all the sudden someone's falling down
the stairs cause they're drunk oh yeah I
get one spot closer in line hilltop and
you get to the top and you can watch our
rated movies at the top because you're
an adult I don't and then there's no
waterslide it's just a movie theater
that's wet absolutely no absolutely not
and that's making me nervous just
thinking about it then you take off your
VR mask you've been in your living room
the whole time
the water has just been what a typical
meet a joke a new technology that makes
you feel wet when you're not wet sick
it's called water but the ease of three
water cool
they are coming to 20 and 20 I invest
thank you my new startup um but I've
been watching like hours of great house
you also were watching time lapses of
like pools being built and cooled yeah I
really like watching time-lapse videos
of things being built because I guess I
was dumb before and didn't know how
things got built so it's really
interesting to learn basic ass [ __ ] like
what go like when you're building a
kitchen like what how they what the
order of operations yeah yeah it's
really cool it's crazy um but I've been
watching a lot of great home videos and
I still like I know you guys want us to
get a big dog and I I've just I've never
had a big dog so I'm a little nervous
but I'm also I'm more nervous about like
the practical stuff like you know right
now if it's Christmas or you know
whatever we can still stay in hotels and
Airbnb ease with three little dogs
because they weigh under a certain total
amount yeah like if we have a big dog
like are we gonna have to board them
separately and then take the little ones
with us like it logistically I think
presents some problems so our life
currently well we can just get a really
tall trench coat and he can sit on my
shoulders and we can pretend to be a
very tall man and his face can be evil
yes I'm just like I don't ever want to
let something like that negate all of
that like day-in day-out like how much
we could give to another dog and how
much another dog could give to us there
are dogs yeah
a big dog would be good for us I know
and I feel like a lot of people too when
they when they consider getting other
dogs they're like I don't want it to
take away my time with my current dogs
which I always worry about
but then when I watch them interact with
each other and like have a really good
time together I'm like it's not all
about me [ __ ] you know what I mean like
your dog enjoys time with other dogs
true that's really true like that that
to me is like when when we got peach and
she was so rowdy and like ran around
marbles and drove him crazy for a while
when they finally warmed up to each
other and now they're like in love with
each other yeah
that to me is giving your dog a proper
experience as a dog because at the end
of the day you're you exists you're on
this planet to like be a dog you know
like you're not here to be my baby as
much as I baby them and treat them that
way like I need to teach you you know
how to be safe and stay alive but like
have an experience as a dog which is
like accepting love from other dogs you
know learning how to trust people and
other dogs and you know all of that
mm-hmm so once marble-like accepted love
from her I was like and he's he's sweet
at the dog park now too like he it's
you're giving your dog a proper
experiences that's so much yeah so I
would love for a greyhound that you know
has had probably a [ __ ] life for them to
come here and all our job is is to just
give you a proper experience as a dog so
you can have dog friends
do dog stuff yeah and just relax yeah
like they should never feel fear or pain
like you it's your job to just exist
here mm-hmm and I'll make sure that
you're happy just exist a little guy you
know yeah sure yeah it'd be really fun I
love to get big sweaters yeah looks like
I can imagine just a big goofy peach or
a big goofy parent well you want a girl
one don't you I think it'd be nice that
piss gonna kill that grass out back boy
well I could boy dog who doesn't piss no
boy boy dog pee doesn't kill grass girl
dog pee kills the grass what yeah it's a
fact okay I'm serious I'm gonna oh man
that really quickly I'm serious check go
ahead check it check the sources here
all right hey Siri what's the difference
between boy dog pee and girl dog pee
[Music]
it's not what it's not what's in there
pee it's how and how much they Pete wait
why do some male dogs squat to pee let's
see let's see
cuteness calm just type in does girl dog
pee kill your grass because you can see
that our grass back there is so nice
every spot that peach pees in it's like
a nice little brown circle now oh my god
yeah oh this is crazy boys versus girls
it's not what's in their pee it's how
and how much they be that matters
females are squat to urinate depositing
a concentrated amount in a single spot
compounding the grass damage male dogs
lift their leg so it's not their pee
it's theirs their method of dispersing
it it's not like female dogs have like
poison in their pee and you made it
sound like female dogs have pretty much
cat pee which is poison I didn't tell a
lie okay well then hermit when he's
tired is also destroying the grass
because he squats when he's tired but
it's in a straight line boy no matter
what position his body's in
about marbles he drops like a single
ounce who's Pete is so light it doesn't
even make it to the ground not even an
ounce sometimes he'll like lift up his
leg for five seconds I'm going to it
nothing's there yeah now on that note
guys we're gonna end the podcast and
think about PE throughout your Monday
and your week and have a wonderful week
also we'll be on twitch pretty much
every night streaming live from outer
space
which is where it's amazing that we have
an internet connection mr. Lyons I'm
lying to you we didn't really get to
space oh yeah look at the background I
bet I made it out of space I don't know
though confessions in futures oh wow
thank you guys for hanging out have a
wonderful week
[Music]